aquí tenemos tres diferentes curvas de
posibilidades de producción de dos
bienes distintos los conejos y las bayas
que ya hemos mencionado en otros vídeos
la razón por la que mostramos tres
curvas es porque claramente cada una
tiene diferente forma y lo que queremos
entender es por qué y en qué situaciones
vamos a obtenerlas aquí nuestra curva de
posibilidades de producción o cpp se ve
como una línea recta aquí se dobla hacia
afuera con respecto al origen en esta
dirección y aquí se dobla hacia adentro
con respecto al origen en esta dirección
lo primero que voy a hacer será
preguntarles cuál de ellas describe el
escenario en el que por cada conejo
extra que atrapamos perdemos más en
términos de vallas otra manera de
plantearlo sería entre más conejos
atrapamos el costo de oportunidad en
términos de bayas se incrementa cuál de
estas curvas describe eso es posible que
ya hayan visto el vídeo de khan academy
sobre el costo de oportunidad creciente
y tal vez reconozcan esta curva pero
vamos a hacer un breve repaso existe un
mundo en el que me alimento de bayas y
puedo recolectar 300 cada día pero
perseguir a este primer conejo que me
pone los nervios de punta paseándose por
allí resulta muy fácil de atrapar así
que no pierdo mucho en términos de
vallas sobre todo porque las vallas que
estoy perdiendo probablemente son las
más difíciles de recolectar digamos que
el costo de oportunidad de ese primer
conejo fue de 20 bayas - observen que
cuando incremento los conejos en uno mis
bayas disminuyen en 20 así que mi costo
de oportunidad es de 20 bayas a cambio
de ese primer conejo pero supongamos que
el segundo conejo es un poco más difícil
de atrapar ya no estoy perdiendo las
frutas más difíciles de recolectar así
que cuando atrapó al segundo conejo he
perdido 40 bayas observen que mi costo
de oportunidad se ha incrementado por el
primer conejo mi costo de oportunidad
fue 20 bayas por el segundo mi costo de
oportunidad es 40 bayas y así seguimos
por el tercero voy a perder 60 vallas
por el cuarto voy a perder 80 bayas y
por el quinto que es lo máximo que puedo
cazar en un día voy a perder 100 vallas
porque ya estoy persiguiendo al conejo
más ágil y astuto y estoy perdiendo
literalmente todas las frutas más
fáciles de recorrer
las que prácticamente están en el suelo
esperando a que las levante lo
importante es que entendamos que esta
curva se dobla hacia afuera respecto al
origen describe un costo de oportunidad
creciente con esta curva analizada cuál
de estas otras describe un costo de
oportunidad decreciente imaginemos un
escenario en el que por cada conejo
adicional que atrapó me vuelvo más hábil
cazando conejos y habrán adivinado que
si esta curva aumenta y se dobla hacia
afuera con respecto al origen entonces
está que se dobla hacia adentro con
respecto al origen debe indicar un costo
de oportunidad decreciente vamos a
asegurarnos de que esto tenga sentido
para ello regresemos al escenario donde
no hago nada más que recolectar bayas
pero ahora tenemos una situación
distinta supongamos que tuve que
entrenarme para poder atrapar al primer
conejo tuve que comprar herramientas
tuve que equipar me me costó mucho
trabajo atrapar al primer conejo y perdí
100 bayas entonces el costo de
oportunidad de ese primer conejo fue de
100 bayas
pero para el segundo conejo mi costo de
oportunidad es de 80 bayas
ya aprendí cómo cazar conejos ya compré
mis zapatos especiales para atraparlos
ya invertí en equipo y ya soy ágil y
además tal vez a esos conejos les gusta
pasar el rato juntos y así seguimos para
el 3er conejo me costó de oportunidad es
de 60 vallas estoy mejorando bastante en
la captura de conejos y podemos ver
claramente que por cada conejo adicional
que atrapó mi costo de oportunidad
disminuye cuando llegó al quinto conejo
mi costo de oportunidad es de 20 bayas
para capturar a ese conejo extra voy a
perder 20 bayas este es claramente un
costo de oportunidad decreciente así que
por deducción podemos decir que esta
línea recta debe representar un costo de
oportunidad constante y eso es de hecho
lo que muestra por cada conejo que
atrapó estoy perdiendo exactamente 60
vallas entonces aquí el costo de
oportunidad de conejos en términos de
bayas es constantemente 60 este es un
escenario que imaginamos en el mundo
ficticio que creamos donde cada conejo
es tan fácil de atrapar como cualquier
otro y cada valla es tan fácil de
recolectar como cualquier otra y donde a
cambio del tiempo
a cada conejo que atrapó pierdo una
cantidad fija de bayas sin importar
cuántos conejos salga a cazar y sin
importar cuántas bayas tenga en ese
momento ese es el costo de oportunidad
constante cuando tenemos una línea recta
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo